[Applaudissements]
mais pourquoi tu me fais comme un singe
réseau cbc baissions je me semblait si
j'avais su mais chantal voulant faire un
autre
[Applaudissements]
je te jure je me suis retourné
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ouf mais franchement pour moi
c'est le vainqueur jouera la fille
garçon qui est pas pressé d'être belle
soirée roots dub et alors il va très
vite c'est la route
et puis quand même la voiture je te jure
j'ai la presse avaient laissé
l'impression qu'ils avaient une ferrari
[Rires]
[Musique]
coutteure make it right guard et tout
doute une claque ça les étals me
gaiement fouet
y'a bien il ne double tout à les renier
dit non tu sais combien j'ai de chemins
non j'ai 500 chevaux m'effondrais
petites routes etc qui se paye ariège
est une force de la marque il tombe dans
la mare et le tracteur du passé
[Rires]
vous venez ou derrière elle un truc j'ai
quelque chose et là tu peux pas 30 et le
cours d'anglais
ah là là c'est ma fille qui me la tête
d'aller au téléphone tout à l'heure
alors je suis pas sûr de shit mois
jusque sur le toit
c'est un garçon qui va prendre le relais
regarde les petites annonces d'un
journal cours d'anglais
enfin de 5 euros de l'heure c'est un peu
cher 35 c'est cher car il trouve par 32
puis d'un seul coup une petite annonce
cours d'anglais cinq ans leur hymne à la
maison et maladresses pis ils frappent à
la porte
la forme est là et c'est ici que
l'anglais à 5 euros
if his between
[Applaudissements]
pardon si tu la joues à la fin et fif
between là la limite
it is due to a hélas interphone n'y a
pas de vision
les mecs et je n'ai rien contre
alors c'est l'histoire préféré de gérard
darmon qui nous raconte depuis trente
ans et c'est vraiment une histoire
rapide et je pensais que sur la bouche
de chantal ça fera un crayon ce qui n'a
pas manqué d'être et on peut saluer le
talent que jean danois